uh
i hear all this [ __ ] chatter
i'm sorry that curse a lot that is quite
all right so this damn chatter about
okay the the last part kind of got me
about if women were truly um they they
loved unconditionally
then they would be in love with these
fat slobs now mind you i like a fat
slide you do what what you're looking at
me like i'm crazy we're questioning it
so you're saying you're okay with the
thicker fellow i yes but i don't agree
with what's being said because at the
end of the day just because you love
somebody unconditionally i don't feel
like you just accept anything that they
are doing if you love somebody
unconditionally listen uh boo you done
put on 77 [ __ ] pounds since we
met come on let's get in this gym but i
think you should do like this
not me i wouldn't do that oh
i started fat but i'm just saying
you buy a you buy like a potato head
like a clay
yes because i would feed that
[ __ ] every day breakfast lunch
and dinner cooks cooks what do you agree
with what do you agree with what donovan
had to say
i mean i i do agree that a lot of the
times that these guys need to like get
their stuff together i don't feel like
the men today are
um like man
like
they i you know what i hate i hate to go
out with a guy and then you're asking me
out right
and then you say um you don't have
anything planned and then it's like oh
well what do you want to do okay
[ __ ] nothing i'm going home
i mean that does not make any sense to
me if you ask me out
you should have a plan if you don't know
me well enough
ask me things about myself that you know
what i mean before the date comes and
then you would be prepared there's no
preparedness don't think that you just
oh i'ma take you out and and
no thought no effort you asking me what
to do to be clear he said that you have
money muscles game and frame what you're
talking about is i guess some game
like know what the deal is know what a
lady needs yep so you do agree with him
that a man needs to have somebody i do
and i also think who is not going to say
that a man needs to have
you know financial stability absolutely
100
i'm not the guy who um i'm not the guy
who calls women gold diggers
if a woman wants to marry or get with a
guy because of money i have zero issue
with that because we like women who look
like this right i'm not gonna shame a
woman and and it's it's in a woman's
biological imperative to get with
someone who can provide for her whether
it's whether it's re i mean back in the
day i'm sure that the cave people you
know uh the women went after the guys
who were the biggest and strongest who
had the biggest i don't know will to be
so whatever the case may be
provisioning is critical to a woman's
and her broods survival i have no
problem with that whatsoever guys who
complain oh women are gold diggers and
this and that and the other
if if if you want to complain about
women being gold diggers then then you
then women don't need to complain about
you wanting hot chicks if you don't want
some you want someone who's physically
attractive well of course i do well then
don't complain about women and their
unrealistic financial uh financial
requirements that's the way i feel about
that i think that men have the same
requirements when it comes to finances
in women that's not what do you know
requirements
nobody listen i have not dated a man i
would not want to date a man that was
not like that didn't want me to
be okay financially as well we are a
team i'm not like
for me what if something happens
what if like anything like with this man
of mine what if you can't work anymore
what if you fall off like that well
there's disability sick i'm not waiting
on no disability i need to be able to go
and get a check and if we're doing that
together then i don't have worries you
don't have words well let me say
something it's not equal though so if
you like that clip click right here to
watch another or if you want to watch
the entire sauce cast click right here
[Music]